foreign
so this is a
I'm going to talk even though those
words on the screen so you're going to
hear it or me
um and you can choose so in 2014 this
puffer fish was named uh and
uh it was 1995. uh this is these are
these are found off of the uh I think
it's pronounced ryuku Islands in Japan
between
um just north of Taiwan
and uh the Riku Islands incidentally
which has a lot of really interesting
stuff in it and I'd like to go at some
point I'm just kind of just a just a
point is there a geological reason they
are uh uh interesting I don't know
um um biologic I I it looks it looks
like a rift edge of some sort but I know
very little about it except when I went
to find figure out where these puffer
fish were and I found once again yet
another fascinating you know animal
behavior story that I was interested in
it's like oh it's in the ryuku it's like
again okay what's going on there I don't
know anyway uh in I think I said the 99
1995 scuba divers had been noticing
these underwater circles
um and didn't know to what to attribute
them and it was a long time it was um a
couple almost a couple of decades
uh before uh in 2013
a paper in scientific reports came out
called role of huge geometric circular
structures in the reproduction of a
marine puffer fish
and so here it is zooming out now you
can see like this this animal has just
made this incredible thing it takes him
I think the BBC said two two weeks oh
but yeah the the scientific paper says
seven to nine days working just
constantly because of course this isn't
you know not Tides change what he's
building here so it's a he it's a he
it's a he and uh the behavioral
description of what's going on actually
came before the scientific name of the
fish so that that's just an interesting
little little glitch right in the usual
order of things where we didn't even
know for sure that this wasn't a species
that had already been named and was just
doing something different then it's you
know it's kin elsewhere until after
the behavior was described and is that
replaying yeah so what we can we can
stop now
um
so males are spending seven to nine days
it's always males they have a big
question for you yeah
do we know it's mating system
I don't see any evidence of it but well
no I I I I can tell you what little I
know and we can predict it well yes uh
so Mel spends seven to nine days
actively making and tending these nests
and there are at least three
characteristics of these nests they're
here to for unknown otherwise in fishy
fish in rafin Fish acting up to Regions
uh and other I mean there's a lot of
fascinating fish behavior of course as
as as we've talked about a little bit
but as many people will will know but
those readily aligned Peaks and valleys
outside of the actual Nest site
um no one's ever seen fish do that
before those placing of the shell
fragments along the Peaks is new in fish
behavior and then the fine sand
particles gathered in the nest site
which you couldn't necessarily see or
maybe you can infer having now seen the
big geometric design from on high that
they specifically are are moving the
sand around to create a central what
ends up being the nest a very fine sand
and those three things the Peaks and
valleys outside the shell fragments on
the Peaks and the fine sand in the
middle in its own geometric but slightly
more regular pattern are all constructed
and maintained before mating before a
female ever shows up sure female shows
up so wait wait I want to predict this
stuff before you okay I don't I don't
know very much but uh yeah go for it
um so
it's going to be a polygenous
mating system not clear
well I'm going to predict that it will
be that males will invest nothing in
that if that's a male they will invest
nothing in Offspring Beyond gametes yeah
I think that's not true not true so
that's part of why I want to do this is
see whether the system is any different
because you know what it of course looks
like is a an aquatic bowerbird analog
are the circles near each other
I don't know uh and I don't know if my
read was uh incomplete or if it wasn't
described
um
they are
after the females visit the nests the
nests mostly collapse and then they get
so that the eggs are laid on fine sand
and they're covered with coarser sand
and it's is likely it seems to me
um that the finest of the sand increases
Fitness of the eggs
these are the locations where the eggs
are laid the middle of that area so
you've got the radial arms outside of
the center like imagine sort of like a
daisy the middle part ends up like a
daisy being the actual reproductive part
so that's very unlike the bowerbird
example yeah well
um
in in some ways in some ways
um but yeah I mean it is it's it's kind
of it is very much actually like a daisy
I hadn't occurred to me before so but
you know in terms of you know the pedals
are basically the The Lure from afar uh
for you know not other daisies but you
know the vectors the pollinators
um to come and pollinate and it's the
center thing it's the center ring
um that is where the eggs are actually
laid so then it might not be a
belliginous system this might be a
mysteriously valuable structure and well
and it's it's mysteriously valuable it
starts collapsing in and of itself
quickly I think
um that there is there are a few days of
sort of male tendon attendance male
parental care and then he goes and
builds another one
and uh it's it's off and starts over
from scratch once the once the first one
so it it may be actually a promiscuous
system in which
um you know if if you have built the
careful nest and you can attract a good
mate that's great and you have that one
thing and then after that whatever it is
a few weeks
you can go and and build another yeah so
this is actually potentially closer to
your frogs
um where a male might have multiple
Wells I see there's no description of
what I found of territoriality uh and
that's not to say that they're not I
would expect that they are I see no
description of therefore uh the quality
of the substrate right uh you know what
what determines where where the fish
choose to to build these nests and um
and aesthetic structures around them
well one thing that's likely to be true
is that structure is likely to be very
difficult to build and maintain if there
are currents and actually you can uh you
can just put it back on while we're
talking as long as we're talking about
these guys uh yes and I think they're in
slightly deep water but yes they're
occurrence and this is this is exactly
true I think I said this already that
the maintenance of the structure is
needs to be constant that basically as
soon as the maintenance stops the thing
to case which you would kind of expect
because if the male if neither of the
fish are going to defend the thing then
what you don't want to do is call is
signal potential egg Predators right
that this is a structure so you would
want it to kind of break down but it's
like these what are those like uh giant
like like Buddhist sand art oh I was
thinking that too right you take
I don't know like weeks months maybe
even to create and they're gorgeous and
intricate and then the point is in part
so they get wiped clean shortly after
they are completed
um in that case there is not a um a
reproductive motive so so what we're
looking at
this seems to be either some new kind of
system or one of two known kinds of
systems it looks like a bower bird kind
of scenario but that doesn't sound like
Barrow bird Behavior if the eggs are
being laid there yeah and it's unlike so
they're they're what something less than
20 I think species something around two
dozen-ish species of bear birds in
Northern Australia and and Papua New
Guinea and there's different there's
different things that different barrier
birds do but they they build these
structures that females the males build
these structures the females are
attracted to but they have some
permanence to them yeah and they do you
know they do Decay it's the tropics and
and they steal from each other the male
Barrel Birds steal from one another and
uh but they're in a spot they are
territorial of the spot and they build a
structure on the spot the bower and that
spot is a spot that any female can come
back to over and over again and unless
something has happened she knows that if
she's in that spot it's going to be that
guy whereas uh exactly steel Bowers they
do but the these are these do not appear
to be
um
territorial yeah um yeah that's why
that's why I think the the bowerbird
connection is superficial I was wrong to
go there I mean it looks like it and the
shell part of the story you know I'd be
curious whether they steal shells from
each other something like that
um and whether there is a display well I
so the thought I had about the shells
was the the functional part of this is
the is the center of the daisy right
it's it's the nest that's where the eggs
are going to be
and my guess is that the eggs are
actually somewhat fragile and they need
a very soft very finely grained sand
nest and the sort of the Petals of the
daisy The Petal the the would-be Petals
of this of this structure that he's
building are the visual attractant from
on far but the shells he's pulling from
inside the nest as an indicator of I've
cleaned the area it's it's clear it's
clear of the debris that would
negatively impact your eggs which is
reminiscent that is again reminiscent of
bower birds and maybe even more so birds
of paradise right the cleaning of the
Dance Floor
is a I don't know if it's Universal but
it's close for for all of those species
um and you know you make a lot of
arguments for why that might be but I
think mannequins too I think mannequins
clean their clean their um little dance
pads in those that have flat pads as
opposed to Sticks maybe not I don't know
I'm more familiar with the stick dancing
uh mannequins but
um but anyway interesting because you've
got features of multiple terrestrial
systems
um I'd be very curious to to know what's
actually going on here yeah
yeah so maybe we should get to the
ryukyu islands and uh right now no no I
died no one thing it's probably very
cold there right now yeah
[Music]